Speaker 1: We haven't heard from or talked about
failed Arizona Republican gubernatorial candidate
Carrie Lake for a little while. That's a good
thing. We should all be glad about that. She
has not gone away and now is she is considering
running for Senate in Arizona. She spoke to the
San Diego, California, County Republican
Party group and she suggested that a new
villain has entered. She suggested that run
back election services illegally sabotaged
or even sabotaged her election. And one of
the things that I want to explain here is.
There are sometimes reports about
this type of thing that I don't
think do a good job journalistically.
So let me first play for you what she
said and then I'll tell you more about it.
Speaker 3: Election Day happened and they
were in a panic and they said, how do we stop this
middle aged woman who's hell bent to shut down our
border? How do we stop her? And they said, we're
going to have to sabotage Election Day. That's
exactly what they did. Starting at 6 a.m., the
machines did not work on Election Day in Arizona.
The machines and 60% of our voting locations
didn't work. There were lines 4 to 6 hours,
and it was primarily in the Republican areas. It
was so bad. What happened was they intentionally
printed the wrong image on the ballot. Run back.
Somebody said it. You're following, aren't you?
Everyone knows that they intentionally printed the
wrong image on the ballot. It jammed the machines.
Speaker 1: 60. Everybody knows it, guys.
Speaker 3: Some of the polling places,
all of them, mainly in the Republican areas,
didn't work. This was a disenfranchisement of the
voter that I've never seen this big in my life.
Speaker 1: So she's mixing multiple different
conspiracy theories and also pretending as
though this run back thing hasn't already been
debunked. And that's how a lot of these people
operate. There is a really irresponsible thing
that sometimes will happen when Carrie Lake or
others put out a conspiracy theory that is new
to some people. Media will sometimes reprint it
without including the fact that it's already been
investigated. It's already been debunked in this
particular case. An expert witness hired by Kerry
Lake's lawyers did at one point testify that
ballots were found printed with the wrong size
image by run back election systems. But it's been
investigated already. Assistant Maricopa County
Attorney Tom Liddy looked into it and said, even
if the ballots were printed in the wrong size,
as the witness claims, it wouldn't matter. He
said the votes would have eventually been counted
anyway. It wasn't an issue. In addition, that
would be partizan in its effect. In other words,
if there were ballots printed on the wrong size
paper or whatever the claim is, they would equally
affect Democratic and Republican voters and all
of these other things. She pulls into it. There
were ten hour lines or five hour lines. There were
lines at some polling places for part of the day.
60% of the machines didn't work. Now, a
few tabulators briefly didn't work. The
Republican Party initially filed suit and then
said, oh, it's been fixed to our satisfaction.
They pulled the suit. All of these things have
been debunked, but it's targeted like a weapon
at people who don't know any better. Also targeted
like a weapon at people who don't know any better.
Continued claims from Kerry Lake that God wants
her to keep fighting for this election. She lost.
Speaker 3: We have to do it.
If we just keep walking away
when they steal our vote, we're
not going to have a country.
Speaker 1: All right.
Speaker 3: Believe me. Let me tell you, there's
a better couple of days. I wanted to lay in the
fetal position in bed. I'm not going to lie.
I'm a strong woman. But there's been a couple of
days where I just said, I don't want to do this.
And God just kicked my butt out of bed and said,
Get back out there. I put you in this for a
reason. I didn't put a weak person in this fight.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, it seems it would have
been easier for God to prevent all of this
if you wanted Kerry Lake to be the governor
and just have her win the damn election.
But God works, works in mysterious ways,
and we don't know who prayed. In
contrast, in counterpoint and the
prayer might have canceled out. Who the
hell knows? It is not stopping. And she
wants to potentially continue this into 2024
with a Senate run. That's very scary stuff.